hey I'm John Cena for those of you
unfamiliar the Internet is a series of
caves so right now I'm going undercover
on the Internet
it's actually me let's start with
Twitter why do John Cena shorts have
loads of pockets that is the design of
the cargo short and is meant to be a
durable and utilitarian half pant light
garment
what is he carrying that's my business
damn it that's where I draw the line
it's like asking me what I'm wearing
into those clothes next I bought this
official John Cena shirt how is it
looking on me tough for me to look at
that picture and not get emotional
the gentleman wearing I just gaffer
seems confident it gets me it's actually
me
Cena Shenzhen dojo mesh wishy John Wayne
pie shrim of methods neon douche wishy
that's pretty much what he said in
hacked-up Mandarin it's a continuing
thing I wish I could learn by immersing
myself in the culture opportunity has
not yet allowed that who knows what is
john cena returning to the ring
Independence Day July 4th Phoenix
Arizona Smackdown live be there or watch
it live on Smackdown or on the WWE web
machine hmm sorry got a little excited
about the return answers.com
where is John Cena at I'm currently
locked in a cave 50 floors beneath the
earth's surface at a classified location
answered
how does wrestling help you it certainly
helped me become invisible I've mastered
that art it also got me my PhD in
economics with a minor in thuggin AMA
tree and very helpful to me over the
years why do girls love John Cena God's
sakes I don't know what kind of question
is that I'm out for the affection of one
young lady Nicole we will Wed and that's
all I care about
YouTube if it breathes or if it's green
you eat it if it breathes or if it's
green you eat it okay am i high or is
John Cena a buffed up alternative
reality version of Bryan Cranston are
you
here's a question Jhansi
that's what you used it for that's what
you use the internet for that's how you
spend your time well played indeed and
enter does anyone remember when Sina was
all on the Fred movies with Lucas I
think I'm the only one you're not ugly
no gosh damn refrigerator
Quora you may not believe it but it's
actually me is John Cena part of the
Illuminati no what is your best John
Cena joke knock knock who's there
John Cena no it's not nobody can see him
why is John Cena the highest-paid
wrestler in the WWE that's false I think
the question here is why isn't John Cena
the highest-paid restaurant at WWE hmm
why does John Cena never turned heel
this is some inside baseball a heel is a
bad person or a person that is unliked
by the audience often times I run out
onto our well-produced stage -
thunderous boos and my theme song has
been remixed by our audience many times
and I quote John Cena sucks so I turn
heel you missed it it happened just
about ten years ago video this is a
robot talking to you I'm kidding it's me
it's me seriously it's actually me
Cena is a fan of Japanese anime and has
mentioned that his favorite anime movie
is Fist of the North Star that is
correct
I saw fist the first time maybe in 14 or
15 and just thought it was really well
done
superheroes fighting super punches and
crazy infinite strikes Yahoo Answers was
John Cena really in the army no here's a
neat fact about the dog tag I don't have
any tattoos
the dog tags contain the first names of
all my brothers and my father and my
mother and Nicole the woman I love so it
is a way for me in a traveling gypsy
life business to keep those very close
to me
very close to me so that's a
little-known fact that you you know now
sent who is more handsome John Cena or
Randy Orton
I need your comments ASAP the answer is
Randy Orton I mean he's got the sleeve
tattoos and he's like got that bad boy
thing going on posted that one what is
my favorite color you catch me in a WWE
ring I really am a fan of loyal blue and
orange and with a hint of green just a
just a hint you know you know you know
if the Undertaker and John Cena had a
match at WrestleMania who would have won
that bout we haven't had it so I can
definitely say I can beat him so I would
have won
certainly John Cena Twitter does John
Cena have formal jorts yes I do
they're actually find it fabric with a
black line down the middle and Oh belt
loops it's tough to wear those are the
t-shirt and wrist bands though John Cena
hosts a show called
American grit and it's been happening
for like a year but I just found out how
do I get on this show step one watch the
show to all your friends to watch the
show tell your enemies to watch the show
if all these people watch it we'll do
another season I'll see you on American
grit season 3 smiles
why does my grandma think that John Cena
died didn't want a process that one tell
her I'm okay or breaks into I mean she
may be okay with that or celebrating it
if she is don't ruin the celebration
just yet forget it out of her system
I am DB it's actually me he has a degree
in exercise physiology and movement
studies check his left-handed I can't do
anything right
writes his own raps absolutely correct
and I am thoroughly in love with the
automobile or core officially on the
Internet's what are the best things
about John Cena first and last name
eight letters it's it's easy to remember
also I eat occasionally maybe more than
other folks and then again I'm burning
that fuel yeah how it is
why hasn't John Cena ever done a UFC
fight I'm not a fan of UFC I'm a fan of
WWE and I do quite well in the heavy
Tony ring who are WWE Superstar John
Cena's real-life friends in the WWE
difficult question because the friends
circle it rotates fast
if somebody that you like and then they
try to beat you up then you have
somebody that beats you up and you don't
like him but you beat him up so much
that you like each other so it's a
rotating merry-go-round of friendship
that never stops so everyone but no one
smack that submit button
reddit does john cena deserve to be
where he is now
hate the word deserve so I'd like to
think that I've earned where I'm at and
I continue to struggle to earn every
inch that I get hate the word deserve
try to draw from a picture of smug
looking Cena got worried looking see
instead worried with intent to smug it's
like I'm better than you
who should retire John Cena I'd like to
think that I could do that into my own
accord unless we can get a suitable
substitute little Farrell or Jason
Statham Channing Tatum would be a good
choice too I think do you say she's all
should you leave it under a tiny island
fall in as well
I could not actually know now I have a
long list of people responded to I hope
you've enjoyed this edition of John Cena
going undercover on the Internet I've
had my fill and I've answered everyone's
questions so so that's that John Cena